ici c'est le paradis des motards on
trouve de tout des plaquettes de frein
aux bidons d'huile en passant par les
gants mais tous ces accessoires ne
s'achète pas sur place mais ici sur
internet l'idée en fait c'est que les
gens n'arrivent pas forcément à trouver
les pièces dont ils ont besoin parce que
les petits détaillants pour pas stocker
toutes les pièces pour toutes les
machines et donc il ya une nécessité en
fait d'avoir des gens qui ont accès à
beaucoup de fournisseurs et qui peuvent
expédier partout en france y compris
dans les zones rurales où c'est très
difficile à trouver en magasin cette
société dit commerce fait le lien entre
les consommateurs et les différents
fournisseurs existants pour multiplier
l'offre impossible donc de stocker les
deux cent mille articles proposés ni de
prévoir les ventes alors shogun moto
fonctionne en flux tendu cette idée
c'est françois qui l'a eu en 2010 ça
fait donc longtemps que je travaille
dans la partie moto l'idée c'est que
j'ai travaillé aussi derrière un
comptoir et j'étais toujours
gêné par ces aspects-là de ne pas avoir
la capacité de faire des recherches
rapides j'avais des clients motards qui
venaient me voir et qui donc arrêter le
demande particulière et je sais pas ou
rechercher potentiellement donc avoir la
puissance d'un outil informatique
adaptée ça permet de
vous retrouver très facilement faute dès
le départ il met en place un logiciel
qui permet d'agréger toutes les données
des catalogues des fournisseurs des
pages et des pages a résumé par marc
catégorie ou encore couleurs un outil
sur mesure pour le e-commerce est un
avantage majeur par rapport à un magasin
physique le mois dernier shogun moto a
mis en ligne un nouveau site pour
retrouver ces données à chaque modèle de
moto les pièces disponibles autre aspect
propre web à la communication tous nos
supports de communication sont orientés
online et on essaie d'être présent sur
tous les endroits où vont les
internautes pour placer notre
communication donc principalement les
moteurs de recherche comme google et
tous les sites affinitaires à la moto
dont tous les sites qui parlent des
moteurs et les clients suivent le
chiffre d'affaires a doublé chaque année
et un douzième salariés va rejoindre
l'équipe un exemple représentatif du
mode de consommation actuel en 2012 le
e-commerce a engendré 45 milliards
d'euros de ventes directes soit 19 % de
plus en nommant